[Musique]
et puis un sentiment d'inachevé tenu de
la valeur artistique qui l'habitait son
passage
avec les léopards et différents albums
qu'il ait pu sortir
les victimes de la loi nome chez toi
aussi et puis la grande amitié qui nous
liait
si bien ici qu'à paris abbey était un
frère un artiste de talent
des segments différents et je le
reconnaissais et j'étais pas le
reconnaître le pays leur connaisseurs
oui c'est un grand joueur attend la
vente de liquidation vers la martinique
au début des années 70 cela je vois
rigoler c'est pas si facile à faire
il a soulevé toute la barre du tout la
martinique et tous les antillais de
paris aussi nous avons eu que de bons
souvenirs
de plus étant donné aux par les médias
au moins les bois sur des gars tout la
même les tous et apprécions vu à part
une eau
nous avons porté mais cette bonne amitié
entre nous et c'était un bon vivement
partageaient les mêmes idées
oui tu as du mal mais moi
albert et
c'est la dimension artistique
parce que c'est très important des
années 70 80
par son charme bien sûr pensante
allemand
aho
pékin s'est beaucoup belle
le martiniquais
dans les vagues
mais avec sa coupe afro
même temps ce un style que
symbolisait ce qu'il ya de plus pur
c'est le
[Musique]
c'est un bon vivant c'est un garçon très
gentil qui est enfin il a été très
gentil
et donc même au niveau de mes parents ma
mère mon père et babel était tout le
temps chez
mais à berne micheline ses deux enfants
là
j'ai payé mes parents défunts et puis on
dévoile albert ses terres
un homme joyeux et puis tu la gentille
serviable aussi et puis dans son groupe
des caisses il a été très bien vu
rigolo voilà